foreign
you here for an abortion too
yeah I discovered a few days ago I
wasn't bleeding out my coup so I guess
I'm Knocked Up is this doctor any good
Mrs Garrison oh that's me
hello doctor looks like I need an
abortion
and abortion yeah I've got one growing
inside me now you're gonna scramble its
brains or just vacuum it out oh look at
that
if you want you can just scramble it and
I'll queef it out myself
Mr Garrison Mrs Garrison Mrs Garrison
you can't have an abortion don't you
tell me what I can and can't do with my
body a woman has a right to choose no I
mean you're physically unable to have an
abortion because you can't get pregnant
I love how they cover so many of the
different jokes like right there he
thought he was just saying like you
can't and he's like my body my choice it
covers they cover like all the different
points in South Park it's so funny look
at the baby in the jar of formaldehyde
on the Shelf oh my God like they're
they're keeping it real in this episode
of South Park this is an old episode
apparently I forget what that's crazy
amount but the fact that they this is
this is the reality of this situation
people grown men screaming insisting
that they're real women and you know and
and just the crassness of abortion and
the reality of it I'm gonna suck its
brains out of scrambled you know
whatever scramble its brains or vacuum
it out whatever he said and you know
we're all just supposed to act like all
of these things are wonderful and normal
that taking your baby's life because
it's an inconvenience to you is a normal
activity that we should just you know
like pulling out a splinter that's what
they're that and or and a grown man is
really a girl it's not it's really it's
like an alpha right like oh come on this
is like just just shut up this is I feel
like I'm in a dysfunctional relationship
where I'm arguing [__] with somebody
and then all of a sudden you know you
know then you just gotta like kick them
out the door A woman has a right to
chose no I mean you're physically unable
to have an abortion because you can't
get pregnant but I missed my period you
can't have periods either you had a sex
change Mr Garrison but you don't have
ovaries or a womb you don't produce eggs
you mean I'll never know what it feels
like to have a baby growing inside me
and then scramble its brains and vacuum
it out oh that's right
but I paid five thousand dollars to be a
woman this would mean I'm not really a
woman if I'm just a I'm just a guy with
a mutilated penis basically yes
oh boy do I feel like a jackass it's
just funny because we're not allowed
these are jokes that we can't even make
anymore you know or so but we couldn't
but people now are like full force
making them again because everybody is
so tired of pretending that that we have
to be that we have to tiptoe on on thin
ice to not hurt everybody's feelings to
hell with everybody's feelings this was
old actually this is like that's what
I'm saying but people are now pushing
this stuff out again and wow but there's
not there have for a long time has not
been new content like this do you know
what I'm saying yeah I know what I'm
saying you know people are afraid of
being canceled nobody cares anymore one
of the things that I've learned a lot
about in the past couple years is
discipline get control of your head
control your mind and learn discipline
and so you stop talking yourself out of
things and so you know Tom Shea the Navy
SEAL who we work with I went through his
21 day challenge where he gave me some
tasks to do every day and part of the
challenge was to wake up every day
commit to doing it and every time I
started to talk myself out of it I would
have an excuse run through my head some
lame ass excuse and there are four main
excuses that he teaches people that are
that ruin lives that's why we're doing
the 21 Day Challenge again together
which Sunny is not excited about because
he's going to have Tom on his ass if you
guys actually would like to do that with
us go to the link in the description
because there's a discount code come and
do it because guaranteed in one area of
your life there's something you're not
doing because you talk yourself out of
it every day you can go to the top of
the description click the link and buy
it with code Sunny fast50 for a nice
discount and we'll be doing it with you
guys we'll be in the zoom calls and
everything it'll be cool
I'm not suspended no more good for you
I think someone's in there no God damn
it no who's taking the [__] occupied I
called dibs on Star One for All recess
Craig you can't call dibs on a toilet
son of a [__]
oh no no no no I cannot go another lunch
break without my toilet time then don't
eat 14 Eggo waffles for lunch fat ass
all right that does it I'm sick of this
[__] and I'm not taking it any longer
you all push me to this
[Music]
how old is this episode three years okay
what the hell you
hell do you potty
I'm transgender
what did you notice the bow I'm not
comfortable with the sex I was assigned
at Birth so I'm exercising my right to
identify with the gender of my choice
now get out of my way I have to take a
[__]
that's legendary
don't give me more issues already have
windy
oh wow this is nice in here the girl's
bathroom's a lot cleaner than the boys
the hell is that Cartman is using our
bathroom dude this is awesome I should
have used the girls bathroom a long time
ago hey hey tell on you it's okay red I
can take a [__] here I'm a dumb chick
too
I want to know just what makes you think
it's okay to go inside the girl's
bathroom because I'm transgender I
looked it up that means I can use the
girl [__] you are not transgender
Eric you don't even know what that means
yeah that means I live a life of torture
and confusion because Society sees me as
a boy but I'm really a girl all right
well if you identify yourself as a girl
you must find yourself attracted to boys
is that right that's actually not true I
can be transgender without it having
anything to do with the gender I'm
attracted to check to stay by us all
right listen Eric Erica listen Eric you
must know why we can't have you in the
girl's bathroom all I know is I'm
transgender and you can't make me go to
the bathroom with the CIS gingers with a
what cisgender it's the politically
correct name for people who aren't
transgender if you identify with the sex
you were born with then you're so I want
to say talk about cisgender so because
they are so obsessed with labels they
wanted to make sure that we had a label
too to get us more comfortable with
labels I don't want to be called take
your label and shove it up your ass I'm
I don't want it just watch just watch
but then cisgender is just normal saying
normal is extremely offensive to people
who aren't in that group who aren't
trust me you don't want this hot potato
just let him use the girls room this
isn't a hurting confused child we're
talking about this is Eric Cartman
nobody else is going to know that you
better just give him what he wants
just test Us in some kind of bathroom
Checkmate actually
it's more like a royal flag
that's too funny W South Park that was a
good one that was a good one so back in
2005 we were still able to tell jokes
about things and laugh about them well
South Park still does do they still say
off color like
um like things that are offensive I
think so yeah where are they aired no
idea I don't watch TV like that really I
think I'm gonna have to start watching
South Park to see if they're if they're
they they have cronies for current
affairs and I know that they just did a
really good one on Prince Harry and his
and his ridiculous wife Megan I like
South Park some of it's like really
funny and then some of it's like really
boring to me so it's like I always felt
the same way about it I either love it
some of them are so funny or some of
them are just like I just this is just
super boring but like those clips were
hilarious just now that was hilarious
and I and I missed that kind of
commentary from 2005 that I that we just
watched I miss those kind of jokes and I
missed that we could have a good laugh
together
um about real facts but we're getting
there we're getting back all right guys
thanks for watching follow me on
Instagram and I'll see you later shoot
me a DMV
[Music]